hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 14 hört zu und spricht nach
die schweiz ist klein
ihre fläche beträgt 40.000
quadratkilometer
ihre fläche wird
trägt 40.000 quadratkilometer
deutschland ist groß
seine fläche beträgt circa 350.000
quadratkilometern
seine fläche beträgt zirka 350.000
deutschland ist circa neun mal so groß
wie die schweiz deutschland ist circa
neun mal so groß wie die schweiz die
fläche
von österreich beträgt circa 80.000
quadratkilometer
die fläche von österreich beträgt circa
80.000 quadratkilometer
österreich ist also etwa doppelt so groß
wie die schweiz österreich
ist also etwa doppelt so groß wie die
schweiz die haut
statt von der schweiz ist bern die
hauptstadt von der schweiz ist bern die
haupt
statt von deutschland ist berlin die
dort von deutschland ist berlin die
haupt
statt von österreich ist wien die haupt
statt von österreich ist wien genf
liegt im südwesten der schweiz genf
liegt im südwesten der schweiz
neben
frankreich neben frankreich dort spricht
man französisch dort spricht man
französisch school liegt im osten der
schweiz school liegt im osten der
schweiz im kanton graubünden im kanton
graubünden
neben österreich
in österreich dort spricht man
rätoromanisch und deutsch
dort spricht man rätoromanisch und
deutsch
berlin
so nah liegt im süden der schweiz
bellinzona liegt im süden der schweiz
thom tessin im kanton tessin
neben italien
dort spricht man italienisch dort
spricht man italienisch schaffhausen
liegt im norden der schweiz schaffhausen
liegt im norden der schweiz
neben deutschland neben deutschlands
dort spricht man deutsch
hat vier landessprachen die schweiz
hat circa acht millionen einwohner
die schweiz
deutschlands
uns hat circa 81 millionen einwohner
deutschlands hat circa 81 millionen
einwohner
österreich hat circa 8,5 millionen
die schweiz und österreich haben fast
gleich viele einwohner die schweiz und
österreich haben fast gleich viele
einwohner im winter ist es kalt im
winter ist es kalt
es gibt schnee es gibt schnee die
temperaturen sind oft unter null grad
celsius
die temperaturen sind oft unter null
grad celsius im sommer ist es warm oder
heiß
ist es warm oder heiß die sonne scheint
die sonne scheint es gibt manchmal
gewitter es gibt manchmal gewitter im
herbst ist es kühl
[Musik]
im herbst ist es kühl
es regnet oft es regnet oft im frühling
ist es warm im frühling ist es warm
[Musik]
es ist oft sonnig es ist oft sonnig
nicht
essen dieses video zu liken zu
kommentieren und zu teilen möchtest du
noch weitere videos sehen dann abonniere
unseren kanal jeden sonntag ein neues
video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video